-My first guests are
a Grammy-nominated
and multi-platinum selling group
you can see in the new special
on NBC, "Olympic Dreams
Featuring Jonas Brothers,"
which airs tomorrow night
at 8:00 p.m.
Here are the Jonas Brothers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
-Why, hello.
-Oh, that's my man!
That is my -- Look at that.
I don't pick favorites,
but come on.
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
Tonight Dough, my man.
Welcome back.
-Oh, me? Sorry.
-Thank you all
for being on the show.
I miss talking to you guys.
I want to talk about
the new special.
I want to talk about new music.
I want to talk about
going back on tour.
There's a lot to talk about
and discuss.
Let's talk about the tour.
Are you excited to be back?
-Incredibly excited.
-Couldn't be more excited.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's been a long year.
But a year and a half of
craziness and, you know,
the fact that we were basically
one of the last tours to go out
pre-COVID, and we'll be one of
the first ones back outdoors
in front of our fans again is
just gonna be a dream come true
after what's been a wild ride.
Hope to see you at a show
if you can make it out to one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. I've been to one.
-Oh, yeah.
-Going on tour, I mean,
are you a little rusty?
Do you remember anything?
Let me just pick a brother.
Joe, you tell me
an instance of some time
things didn't go as planned.
-Yes, you know, things are out
of your control,
and it's big stage,
lots of lights.
You never know
what's going to happen.
And on my birthday, we had
this big sign that said "JB's,"
standing for Justin Bieber,
that we were borrowing from him
for us as Jonas Brothers.
-Yeah. Okay, okay, of course.
Well, yeah, you have to
recycle and reuse. Why not?
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
And it lights up on fire.
Well, it was one of
our first times using it.
And this was at Woodstock,
and the fire alarm goes off,
and sprinklers just start
pouring on us on stage.
So we're almost in a flood now
and the audience has to leave
before we can
even make the encore.
But for me, selfishly,
we got to my after party
for my birthday quicker,
but I felt bad
about not finishing the gig.
[ Laughter ]
-Kevin, I saw this video
of your daughters
doing their best impression
of you guys, of Jonas Brothers.
How do they see you?
Do they see you
as uncles and dads
or do they know you from TV?
-No, no. They see us
as the people they saw
on "Hannah Montana" in that
one episode we did with her.
-Interesting.
-They're completely obsessed
with that show now,
and they think we're
those people every day.
-Yeah, I want to show a video of
your daughters
impersonating you guys.
Here's Kevin's daughters.
Check this out. Cute.
-I'm Nick.
-I'm Joe.
-I'm Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I'm Kevin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everybody wants to be Kevin.
-Yeah, everybody wants to be
Kevin, yeah.
-Yeah, she did say that
Nick is the funniest
when his hair is puffy,
so bringing it back
to that "Hannah Montana" days.
-It's getting puffy once again.
It's growing out here,
so she can be real happy.
-Yeah, exactly, bud.
You guys have a memoir
coming out,
by the way, entitled "Blood."
Obviously because you're family.
-We wrote it with blood.
-No, actually,
that's not the reason.
We're going to take a note out
of all the YouTubers
that are having
these boxing matches.
We're going to have
a big UFC match.
It's gonna be us vs.
the Hemsworth brothers.
-Oh, my God! Oh, no!
Don't do it!
Don't do it, please!
-The Hemsworths haven't e-mailed
us back yet.
but I think it's gonna be big.
-Yeah, maybe there's a couple of
Hemsworths out there
that we don't know of
that you can maybe
challenge or something.
-A little bit closer
to our height as well.
-Exactly, yeah.
Well, congrats on that.
And I want to talk about
your show, "Olympic Dreams."
Kevin, can you set this up?
-Yeah, the show,
we're really excited about.
We got the opportunity
to pretend like
we're Olympic athletes
for a week or so.
And about a day of training
with some incredible athletes
and then actually compete
against each other.
And they filmed it
for the audience at home
to watch and laugh at us.
It's been great so far.
-Nick, you broke a rib
doing this.
Are you okay now
and what happened?
-I am, you know, now I think,
seven, eight weeks
removed from the injury.
I'm doing a lot better.
Nearly 100%.
It's not all that exciting.
I mean, it's going to be
in the show,
which people should watch
tomorrow night.
But basically, you know,
we trained with
real Olympic athletes
who have been doing this since
they were probably
four or five years old.
And so, when they said to us,
"Yo, this is easy.
You're gonna do the BMX track
that 11-year-olds do."
We thought, "We got this."
What they didn't tell us
is that these 11-year-olds
have been doing it since
they were 3 or 4 years old.
So cut to the three of us
trying to do that,
and, you know, I took a spill,
one of two spills
I took on the show,
and broke my rib.
-Kevin's laughing, by the way.
-It was great.
[ Laughter ]
-It couldn't have been
worse timing
because that week following,
we shot the music video
for our song with Marshmello,
"Leave Before You Love Me."
I was hosting
the Billboard Music Awards
and performing with the brothers
and we had "The Voice" finale
all in the same week of my --
[ Laughter ]
-We get it, Nick, you're famous.
We get it, Nick, you're famous.
Geez.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys are the greatest.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here are Nick, Kevin
and Joe Jonas
in "Olympic Dreams
Featuring Jonas Brothers."
It's gonna air tomorrow night
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.
Take a look.
-Run through the hurdles,
don't slow down, and jump, okay?
-Hey!
-Okay. Okay.
-You got some height, Nick.
-Not too bad.
-Yes.
-Okay.
-That was beautiful form, Kev.
-That was beautiful.
-Staying low through those --
-Hey, how's it going, bros?
Good to see you.
-Trying to stay --
Right, you're supposed to stay
through the power though, right?
-You were.
-Am I doing that?
-Better, but still --
I think you're still --
-No, it's not better.
Is it better than them
is the question.
-Kevin needs
a lot of motivation.
-Kevin's already out here
fishing for compliments.
-I need to know I'm doing okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm Kevin. I'm Kevin.
-I'm Kevin!
-Jonas Brothers, everybody!
"Olympic Dreams
Featuring Jonas Brothers"
airs tomorrow at 8:00 p.m.
on NBC.